e mes chers amis puisque j'ai été
interpelé amicalement d'abord je veux
dire à nadine qu'on a tous été très
content de l'entente dans ce micro et
qu'elle participe à la diversité
diversité des expressions et que ça m'a
fait plaisir
alors nadine a soulevé un problème c'est
vrai faut-il un ministère de
l'immigration est un ministère
l'intérieur je m'en expliquer j'ai
observé une chose chaque fois que j'ai
eu un ministère de l'immigration
ça devenait le ministère du droit de
l'immigration contre le ministère de
l'intérieur qui était le ministère de la
sécurité française et j'ai pensé que le
seul ministre de l'immigration possible
ce ministre l'intérieur parce que c'est
lui qui doit faire respecter l'autorité
de l'état la sécurité et les frontières
dans notre pays
si tu crées deux administrations la
logique mais oui mais je pensais tu veux
que j'ai eu tort de créer un mystère
l'immigration et donc que j'ai eu raison
de le supprimer
parce que je pense que le sol militia
l'immigration c'est de mettre dans les
mains du ministre de l'intérieur la
décision qui est la sienne de faire
respecter les frontières les titres de
séjour et de procéder au contrôle des
papiers de ceux qui sont sur le
territoire et qui ne devraient pas y
être
alors c'est un débat qu'on aura et qu'on
pourra poursuivre voilà merci en tout
cas je suis très heureux de de la
liberté ton et la liberté des changes
que nous avons entre nous